hello and welcome to this video do I
have that stop sound it's really low
right a little bit of sound
let me check this yeah no I have sound
okay yeah just like I need this
reassuring thought thought somehow I
need that okay so I'm playing an entire
reverse leningrad line okay he just
gives me gifts me the pawn as yes a
sarin probably would would put it and
well i it has a bit of compensation for
that but let's see if it is enough i had
to give up my dark-squared bishop but
the beetle porn is a good point to take
here because it is not just a pawn but
also part of the Queen side the whole
Queen side structure like okay let's put
this here I want to prevent him from
playing c4 that's about what I want to
do yeah he certainly has a form lined up
really moving the rook had sir not very
it wasn't expected now taking I don't
like to take this I'd rather want to
play the night here and try Bishop j5
even though maybe while it's just
playing G for now no I think you should
do something like that what he's doing
is a little bit on the slow side
you know you need to get some sort of
compensation for what some idea at least
can go easy for as default hanging
honestly I don't see a move in any way
that she has I mean this this is like
this is not what you want to play I
can't even go Knight to e4 and I think I
will do that those traits look look fine
Knight be one okay let's let's go here
that's annoying
there is no c4 here between f2 new so
take it I can just take that
maybe g-form to at least muddy the
waters a little bit it's not something
that threatens all that much you know
the question is where to go
Bishop c8 maybe you could just go to see
aid or to e6 but c6 I mean now
why not e6 okay Bishop f1 let's just
shut this down I mean I have an extra a
and B pawn so if the King side gets shut
down like it is now I should win quite
easily on the Queen side the a pawn
alone is worth a ton and currently the
the the White Queen side cannot even
move like the knight would be one for
example has exactly no square - Gocha
time to get some to get some beverage
yeah what White has no sensible move
here okay what is what is he I'm sure
see three maybe no they're not go I can
can go back here voluntarily it's not a
bad square anyway like a five six seven
and then get the pawns rolling
and I can also start with b5 but no okay
him it's not g3 move probably not
I can make it a little bit more
difficult for him to play h5 though so
we should have seven maybe and what I
also showed you and what I didn't join
next last move is to play somewhat
quickly because he is burning quite a
good good amount of time and I should
try to not get into any time pressure
because the position is just so utterly
winning oh yeah I mean a queen trade
when you're three pawns up is kind of
okay and now it's going to be four
so let's open the H file and then go for
an attack on the king it should be seven
okay that's something I can stop yeah I
don't want him to take actually double
vania but I have okay Jade yeah that's
the end of the clock so there there
shouldn't be any scary time moments yeah
this is coming to me five so should be
ready to take it
too many puns
b5 is going to win the bishops I am so
wide retreat it
mmm
yeah three points is just too much
and that's a new queen I don't think
this is a sound pawn sacrifice right
you can I think rap quite safely there I
mean why do I should probably play
Knight c3 at this point I'm attacking b2
and that engine saying Knight h6 a
pretty low battery here on that notebook
but the engine is giving weird things
here b6 know it's it's it's okay again
Knight c3 yeah but I have to plug my
notebook in yeah it just has very low
power and therefore the engine is also
quite a weaker yeah I don't think that
you have enough him
you should not sacrifice that pawn white
has of course the better development but
the position is extremely closed so I'm
really not not thinking that it is too
great and I'm probably you should avoid
deform and back here I think black is
clearly better you're not opening up the
position any time soon and yeah well
also has weaknesses so the whole dark
squares a week some like here I should
be in excellent shape your knight be one
but should probably rather take like I
expected that to happen but it's it's of
course very good for black
there's just no compensation for the
pawn at all and I can always play f6
soon to kick out the e5 Knight if I like
to do that yeah in the game I was
winning yet another pawn and there
really wasn't enough calm
here it's interesting and the engine
wants to take and play 93 and gives
white still quite reasonable chances
engine says that this is a little bit of
compensation but it's a very very low
depth so I'm sorry the engine it's not
really helping when the battery is
totally down because it completely
yeah throttles the whole CPU okay so f5
now after g5 and this is basically over
don't think that there was anything
particularly interesting happening after
that it's just just it's just too much
material no it's just far too much
material and easy win for black this
line with Queen to b6 is not a bad way
to play to prevent white from castling
and detecting the pawn I think this is
correct but I don't know exactly how it
is some continued after this move white
tries to play quickie for maybe then
Queen e2 it should definitely be fine
the engine here gives Bishop g4 I don't
know again it's a relatively weak engine
under those circumstances ok guys thanks
for watching next game I will have the
power plugged in and better supported
analysis thanks a lot for watching bye
bye